hoy nuestra patria enfrenta a una triple
crisis iniciada en noviembre de 2009 con
el golpe de estado' y profundizada con
la pandemia la crisis política que
genera un gobierno que no salió de las
urnas ni del respeto de los reglamentos
de la asamblea legislativa plurinacional
ni mucho menos de su apego a la
constitución política del estado la
crisis sanitaria producto de la
aparición de la pandemia mundial del cob
y 19 en bolivia y a la que el gobierno
de facto no pudo ofrecer ninguna
respuesta integral adecuada la crisis
económica derivada de la incapacidad del
gobierno para generar estabilidad y
crecimiento con justicia social
en un año se retrocedió en todas las
conquistas del pueblo boliviano
hay quienes han argumentado que la
situación actual es producto única y
exclusivamente de la acción de ese
enemigo silencioso llamado job y 19
pero quiere echarle toda la culpa a la
pandemia en esta situación no es
correcto la crisis se venía conformando
en el horizonte desde el golpe de estado
tras el cambio abrupto de la política
económica y se agudizó a la raíz de los
efectos de la crisis sanitaria